i know by the way i'm a
huge admirer of alexa navalny
who alexei navalny is the russian
the effective leader of the opposition
who's in prison at the moment do you
know who he is no i don't
know i don't know who he is so um
you've got to um danny uh he's a hero
you've got a uh he's put out
so what happened to him was he
um doesn't like putin and he's after him
and he's getting traction putin's been
in power for 20 years
there are russian voters now 18 19 20
year olds
who are only known vladimir putin in
power and that's
boring and also russia isn't doing very
well
because it is fundamentally horribly
corrupt
and alex saying about me calls vladimir
putin the czar of corruption
i've met navalny a couple of times his
supporters get stabbed and tasered and
beaten up
but the valley keeps them going for it
last year he was poisoned
uh he was on a plane started screaming
fell into a coma the pilot landed the
plane in siberia
doctors raced out jabbed him with the
right stuff
and then he was flown to germany where
the german
doctors discovered he'd been poisoned by
novichok
novichok is a nerve agent you cannot buy
this in a shop
it's created by the russian secret
states
and they poisoned this guy he survived
he's got balls of steel and he went back
to russia
and has just been arrested and he's
banged up again he's serving
three years or they've given him three
years basically on trumped up charges
he's inside for two days when a video
he's made pops up he made it in germany
and it's about putin's palace he says
watch the video and it's fantastic it's
in russian but subtitled in english and
it's like two hours long and it's
wonderful stuff but putin has built
himself well putin's cronies have built
him a billion pound
like a one point one a heart sorry
a one point
five billion dollar palace on the
uh shores of the black sea
with toilet brushes that are worth seven
hundred dollars
crazy absolutely crazy with a with a
hooker room are you a room where you can
smoke hubble bubble pipes
with a strippers pole in it and you can
see the detail of it
and the point is that it's created it's
been paid for
by his um rich scum oligarchs
but you know it's his because you can't
go then if you try and go there
you get arrested by the secret police
and there's a two mile exclusion zone
ships can't go near it because they
might be a
terrorist thing it's the president's
palace
this video goes up two days
after the values are uh arrested because
they've held it back
and 120 million people have watched it
on youtube
so it's it's really big now this
is now navalny now putin
never calls navalny by his name kind of
like lord voldemort
and i've actually met the van and i said
and on my twitter
i'm on twitter john sweeney raw and um
i there's a film called taking on putin
which is somewhere on youtube but um
i actually challenge um oh
i say to navalny why why does um
why doesn't he name you and he said
because i'm lord voldemort
the thing about navalny he's very very
funny
um he's got a real wit and uh he's got a
mate who's a bit
fat and the values he's he's um
he's got a beautiful wife two lovely
kids um but he's got a fat
sidekick um who who's no more forgotten
who who does the kind of grungy bits and
there's one moment where
navalny's sitting um he talks
very intensely directly to camera it's
obviously in a nice cafe somewhere in
germany where he's
um um talking all this stuff
it's very very funny and then it cuts to
his fat mate on a little dinghy
driving towards we're going to the
palace
so it's it's genuinely really really
funny
and um and and brave as
[ __ ] so um
people would say what the [ __ ] did the
valley go back to russia because they
tried to kill him they tried to kill him
and the thing is they could kill him in
germany they could kill him in britain
they could kill him in the states
so he he's daring them to kill him and
he's incredibly brave but navalny has
said
i don't agree with twitter switching off
trump really because navalny
needs um needs social media
because he's avoiding the the mainstream
media the mainstream media and russia
won't deal with him because it's
controlled by the kremlin
the difference for me is the attack on
the capital
is a line in the sand and basically as i
said earlier but the problem is that
trump lost
the smart brave people around him and
said don't do this boss because it's
it's
a crossing of the line and i can't
do not think it's right to do this in
particular
if your supporters are anonymous because
then
then what what means is that if you're
you're trying to how can you defend
democracy if people
threaten to kill you anonymously
in this space um i don't
believe in free speech
the whole way but i'm saying i also note
with some anxiety
that navalny disagrees with me but i
think russia is
and the united states two different
places so that uh
i i'm i'm putting forward the counter
argument
but i'm sticking with i'm pleased that
um
that trump has kicked off twitter didn't
you
you've done at least one extensive
interview with trump personally right
i've done i've um yeah
and that was regarding some sort of
hotel he was building in scotland
yeah he's he's such a [ __ ]
which i'm going to bring up because this
interview is going to last forever
i'm going to go grab my bottle of
tequila too so yeah hold on let's do
this now let's
um trump's a [ __ ] hold that thought i'm
going to get the bottle
perfect there you go what do you have
there
so advertising uh amarone della
valpolicella
and this is from um
somewhere beautiful in italy negra devil
polycella
italia doesn't say where
it's really nice can you get that in the
united states
yeah yeah yeah um
but i would um yes
i'm sure you can oh well anyway um
it's here's what i'm drinking
you're drinking um george clooney
tequila it's called casa amigos
yeah yeah yeah uh he's good george
[Laughter]
um